ECONOMY IS RED-HOT.
WHEN EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HAS TO ADMIT IT.
CHECK OUT THIS REPORTING.
IT'S HEADLINED, WE RAN OUT OF
WORDS TO DESCRIBE HOW GOOD THE
JOBS NUMBERS ARE.
AND IT ALSO WENT ON TO SAY, THE
ECONOMY IS IN A SWEET SPOT WITH
STEADY GROWTH AND BROAD
IMPROVEMENT IN THE LABOR MARKET.
JUST LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FELL TO AN
18-YEAR LOW AT 3.8% IN MAY, AS
THE ECONOMY ADDED 223,000 JOBS.
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT FELL TO A NEW
RECORD LOW AT 5.9%.
DOWN SHARPLY FROM THE 6.6% IN
APRIL.
AVERAGE HOURLY EARNINGS, I LOVE
THIS, INCREASED 2.7% FROM A YEAR
EARLIER.
MEANWHILE, TRUMP IS DRAINING THE
SWAMP BY SLASHING 3,000 FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT JOBS IN MAY, FOR A
TOTAL OF 24,000 SINCE HE TOOK
OFFICE.
HERE NOW, THE MAN CHARGED WITH
KEEPING THE TRUMP BOOM GOING,
LARRY KUDLOW, THE HEAD OF THE
NATIONAL ECONOMIC COUNCIL.
LARRY, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
WE APPRECIATE IT TONIGHT.
I WAS THINKING BACK ON, YOU
KNOW, NOVEMBER 10th, 2016, ALL
THESE -- OH, MY, GLOBAL MARKETS
ARE GOING TO COLLAPSE, THE STOCK
MARKET'S GOING TO CATECAIT KRA T
MARKET'S GOING TO CATECAIT KRA R
MARKET'S GOING TO CATECAIT KRA .
THE
TH
"T
"THE
"THE N
"THE NEW
"THE NEW Y
"THE NEW YOR
"THE NEW YORK
"THE NEW YORK TI
"THE NEW YORK TIME
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" H
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAD
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAD T
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAD TO
ADMIT TODAY THAT THINGS ARE
CRAZY GOOD.
>> WOW.
BECAUSE I REMEMBER MY GREAT
FRIEND PAUL KRUGMAN THRASHING
ALL OF US AND SAYING THAT THE
ECONOMY WAS GOING TO GO INTO A
DEEP RECESSION, AND THE STOCK
MARKET WAS GOING TO CRASH.
I GUESS THE DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT,
THE REALITY.
TODAY WAS ANOTHER GREAT DAY FOR
JOBS, UP 223,000.
WAGES ARE RISING.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS FALLING.
>> Laura: WE WENT THROUGH IT
ALL.
>> SMALL BUSINESS NUMBERS DID
VERY WELL AGAIN TODAY.
MANUFACTURING REPORTS DID VERY
WELL AGAIN TODAY.
IT'S NEVER PERFECT, BUT WE'RE ON
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, THE BIG ISSUE
FOR MY CRITICS AND THE
PRESIDENT'S CRITICS AND THE
ECONOMIC AREA, YOU'LL NEVER GET
TO 3%, YOU CAN'T BEAT 2%.
WELL, RIGHT NOW, WE'RE RUNNING
FOUR QUARTERS, 2.9%, AND THE
SECOND QUARTER, ACCORDING TO THE
ATLANTA MODEL GDP NOW, 4.7%,
THAT'S THEIR ESTIMATE.
I'LL BE HAPPY WITH 3%.
>> Laura: WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME
THE ECONOMY HAD A QUARTER AT 4%?
>> I PROBABLY CAN'T EVEN
REMEMBER THAT.
I'LL SAY THE 1990s.
>> Laura: YEAH, PROBABLY '94.
>> '4, '5, '6, '7.
>> Laura: "NEW YORK TIMES,"
TRUMP TOUTS JOB REPORT BEFORE
OFFICIAL RELEASE, BREAKING
PROTOCOL.
THIS IS WHAT THEY SEIZED ON.
BECAUSE ALL THE OTHER STUFF WAS
REALLY GOOD.
SO TRUMP TWEETED OUT THIS
MORNING, YOU KNOW, LOOKING FOR
THOSE JOBS REPORTS.
>> THAT'S ALL HE SAID.
LIKE THE REST OF AMERICA,
LOOKING FOR THE JOBS REPORT.
LISTEN, BY LAW AND CUSTOM, ALL
RIGHT, I GET THE JOBS DATA THE
NIGHT BEFORE.
I GET IT FROM MY PAL AT THE CAA.
WE TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
I CALLED IT, TO LET HIM KNOW,
BECAUSE IT WAS A GREAT NUMBER.
IT WAS A PRIVATE NUMBER, A
SECRET NUMBER, YOU CAN'T PUT IT
OUT.
I GOT HOLD OF HIM ON AIR FORCE
ONE.
>> Laura: HE'S ABOUT TO TWEET IT
OUT, THOUGH, EXCITED LIKE A KID,
EXCITED ABOUT THE NEWS.
HE WANTS AMERICA TO WIN.
HE WANTS TO WIN.
>> HE DOES WANT TO WIN.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I FIGURED, I DIDN'T WANT TO
BOTHER HIM COMING HOME FROM A
I THOUGHT HE NEEDED SOME GOOD
NEWS, HE GOT GOOD NEWS.
THE TAX CUTS, THE ROLLBACK OF
REGULATIONS, THE OPENING OF
ENERGY, THE PROTECTION OF SOME
OF OUR OWN TRADING RIGHTS.
>> Laura: OH, BUT THIS IS WHAT
SET EVERYONE OFF, THEY SAID
TRUMP WOULD BACK OFF ON THIS
DEAL, ON THE TARIFFS, IT WAS ALL
A PLOY.
BUT NOW, LOOKS LIKE HE MEANS
BUSINESS.
ALL THESE PEOPLE CRITICIZING
HIM.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO PREDICT
WHAT TRUMP IS GOING TO DO.
TRUMP'S TRADE WAR IS BAD FOR
BUSINESS.
THIS IS A WEIRD SELF DEFEATING
WAY TO ALLIES.
THE TRUMP TRADE SLUMP MAY YET
HAPPEN.
>> MAY YET HAPPEN.
>> Laura: HOW A TRUMP TRADE WAR
COULD SLOW DOWN THE GLOBAL
ECONOMY.
TRUMP'S TRADE WAR WOULD BE VERY
BAD FOR MANY AMERICANS.
AND THAT JUST -- THAT'S JUST A
SMATTERING OF SOME OF THE
HEADLINES.
>> ONE THING I'LL SAY.
PEOPLE LOOKS
PEOPLE LOOIN
PEOPLE LOOING
PEOPLE LOOING A
PEOPLE LOOING AT
PEOPLE LOOING AT T
PEOPLE LOOING AT THI
PEOPLE LOOING AT THIS
PEOPLE LOOING AT THIS S
PEOPLE LOOING AT THIS STU
PEOPLE LOOING AT THIS STUFF
SHOULD UNDERSTAND WHEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP SAYS SOMETHING, THEY
SHOULD BELIEVE IT.
BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON IT.
SO, LOOK, I DON'T WANT TO SEE A
WORLD TRADE WAR, TARIFF WAR, WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING REMOTELY
LIKE THAT.
FROM DAY ONE, WE'VE GONE AFTER
CHINA.
THEY DESERVE IT.
THEY'RE UNFAIR AND ILLEGAL
TRADING PRACTICES HAVE TO BE
DEALT WITH.
THEY'RE STEALING OUR TECHNOLOGY.
THAT HAS TO BE DEALT WITH.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT OUR ALLIES,
CANADA, THE EU?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS TALKED TO
THEM.
IN THE ANNOUNCEMENTS YESTERDAY
WE SPENT A LINE OR TWO SAYING
WE'RE STILL IN DISCUSSION.
PARTICULARLY SINGLING OUT CANADA
AND EUROPE.
WE'RE STILL IN THAT DISCUSSION.
BUT LOOK, WE'VE ASKED THEM TO
HELP US ON THIS STEEL PRODUCTION
AND OVERCAPACITY.
WE'VE ASKED THEM TO HELP US ON
WHAT THE PRESIDENT CALLS
RECIPROCITY.
SO IF WE SELL AN AMERICAN CAR IN
GERMANY, WE PAY A 10% TARIFF.
IF THEY SELL A CAR IN AMERICA,
IT'S 2.5%.
WHY DOESN'T THE REST OF EUROPE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
LOOK, I'M NOT A BIG TARIFF GUY.
I'M KNOWN AS A FREE TRADER.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT SAID
HE'S A FREE TRADER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Laura: HE WANTS A FAIR TRADE.
>> THE SEE, LOOK IT.
FREE TRADE WILL HELP THE
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
OKAY?
BUT, YOU CAN'T HAVE FREE TRADE
IF ALL THESE COUNTRIES, MOST
PARTICULARLY CHINA, ARE ENGAGING
IN UNFAIR AND ILLEGAL TRADING.
>> Laura: THEY'RE SUBSIDIZING
THEIR COUNTRY.
CANADA DUMPED $200 MILLION IN
TOYOTA PRODUCTION IN CANADA.
THEY'RE SUBSIDIZING, NOT TO THE
TUNE OF WHAT CHINA'S DONE -- SO
PEOPLE GET WHY THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES WE HAVE TO RIGHT THE
SHIP HERE WITH THESE TARIFFS.
CHINA, THE TRADE DEFICIT FOR
LAST YEAR, $375 BILLION IN GOODS
AND SERVICES.
CANADA, $18 BILLION.
MEXICO, $71 BILLION.
JAPAN, $69 BILLION.
GERMANY, $65 BILLION.
IN DEFICITS.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" AND
THE FREE TRADER FRIENDS, THAT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THAT DOESN'T MATTER.
BUT THEN THEY WONDER WHY PEOPLE
TURNED OUT TO VOTE FOR TRUMP.
MANUFACTURING JOBS, BLUE COLLAR
JOBS, USED TO HAVE 18 OF THE 20
STEEL MANUFACTURERS IN THE
WORLD, NOW WE HAVE TWO.
AND NONE OF THE STEEL COMPANIES
IN THE TOP TEN TODAY, LARRY.
>> LOOK, WE ACTUALLY RUN A
SURPLUS ALL IN WITH CANADA.
>> Laura: YOU'RE DOING THE
TIMBER THING, RIGHT?
>> THE SERVICES THING.
>> Laura: GOODS AND SERVICES,
IT'S $18 BILLION.
>> THE ISSUE HERE, I DON'T
REALLY THINK IT'S TRADE DEFICIT,
THAT'S NOT MY FAVORITE METRIC,
THE ISSUE HERE IS TARIFFS AND
NON-TARIFF BARRIERS.
SO THEY WON'T LET US SELL TO
THEM, THEY WON'T LET US EXPORT
TO THEM, WE ARE THE MOST
COMPETITIVE ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
A RECENT POLL JUST SAID WE
BOLTED BACK INTO FIRST PLACE.
THE OECD SAID WE'RE THE FASTEST
GROWING ECONOMY.
>> Laura: BUT THE TARIFFS ARE
GOING TO RUIN IT ALL, THAT'S
WHAT THE FRIENDS AT THE JOURNAL
ARE SAYING.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN HIS HEART
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD GUY.
HE'S A FREE TRADE GUY.
LET'S CLEAR AWAY -- THE WHOLE
WORLD TRADING SYSTEM, BY THE
WAY, HAS BEEN BROKEN FOR YEARS
AND NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
A LOT OF PRESIDENTS HAVE GONE
DOWN THIS ROAD AND HAVE NEVER
DONE ANYTHING.
HE'S GONE DOWN THIS ROAD AND
WON'T STOP.
>> Laura: 1990'S CHINA ECONOMY
IS SMALL AS THE SIZE OF ITALY.
NOW I BELIEVE IT'S TEN TIMES THE
SIZE OF CANADA.
JAPAN, EXCUSE ME.
>> FAIR TRADING, AND FREE MARKET
CAPITALISM WILL BEAT THE
CHINESE.
I GIVE THE PRESIDENT A LOT OF
HIGH MARKS FOR STICKING TO IT.
AND HE IS NOT GOING TO LET GO.
FOLKS, LISTEN TO HIM AND COME --
WE'RE IN A FAMILY SQUABBLE WITH
OUR ALLIES IN EUROPE.
>> Laura: JAPAN COULDN'T KEEP
GOING.
>> WE'LL HAVE PLENTY OF TALKS.
THEY'VE GOT TO DO THEIR PART.